Ola is with us Kohl's in Michigan take
all welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you takes my call sure man how can
I help
I just want to get your you thought I'm
something my wife and I just started FPU
back in January we're doing it really
intense right now Estelle baby said to
we should be all paid off in October for
a one-year anniversary great are we can
do a lot of research kind of a game plan
so we can like hit the ground running
and get out of debt our thought between
her and I we were thinking we should in
the area we're living in right now we
want to buy our first home save up for
our first home that the intent paying
that home off early and then turning
into a rental property I'm just trying
to get your thoughts on that I've I've
had resistance from friends of mine
that's hold this idea to and they said
paying up your mortgage rate is stupid
you know there's much better investments
we made I'm pretty confident in that
I've been learning from listening to you
I just want to get your thoughts on that
that game plan that we're trying to
formulate for him get out of debt if
broke people are making fun of your
financial plan it means you're on track
okay if fat people are making fun of
your diet it means you're on track and
that's that's what you're talking about
here so who gives a crap what broke
people think about paying off your
mortgage they're ridiculous I own I own
several hundred million dollars in real
estate and I pay cash for every bit of
it okay
now would I do your deal or what I pay
off the house yes I'd get the house paid
off then the second step is where you
may have a problem because I don't want
you to go back into debt once you've
done that in order to get a rental
because let's say you pay this house off
and then you save up a down payment and
buy another house and then you have a
mortgage on your personal home but you
have a paid for rental if you had sold
the paid for rental you probably could
have paid cash for the personal home so
it in essence is if you borrowed on your
personal home to buy a rental in that
scenario so if you can save up enough to
cash for the new house and keep the paid
for rental game on but once you get that
sucker paid off we're going to sell it
and roll it into the next house unless
you can pay cash for the next house
because the number one thing we found
number one and number two things we
found in the millionaire study and I
found this long before the millionaire
study was done the study we did for
Chris Hogan's everyday Millionaire book
our MC research team airtight research
found that the two primary ways that
people became millionaires was their
401k in the or I at Roth IRAs and
they're paid for house
it wasn't borrowing on your home to buy
rental real estate that was not one of
the ones that get wasn't that was not
even in the top twenty reasons that
people became millionaires and so this
idea that borrowing me think about it if
you had a paid for rental right now and
a house payment versus a house that you
lived in that was just paid for in the
middle of all this kovat garbage
how much differently you'd feel 100%
debt-free with a pile of cash right now
looks pretty dadgum good